[Applause]
wiggins misses looney fighting for it
oh no
has a foul
[Applause]
instead of just his first timeout it's a
loony rebound foul and that'll be free
throws the other way oh no
oh you can't have that play happen
not with the lead
oh you just can't do that
[Applause]
let's see how egregious it was
that's top i'd love to see him let him
play there
loose ball
[Applause]
[Applause]
three tenths of a second to play
i forgot we were on tv for a second
that was so good
calden johnson who had the biggest
rebound against utah that secured pop
the record win
steps in and gets the biggest rebound of
the night here in golden state
absolutely unbelievable
i'm figuring if he misses this we're
going to overtime kelden somehow comes
down with it flips it up off the glass
that's got to be game i mean
i don't know how golden state is going
to manage to score here with 0.3 they
can advance the basketball but you put
somebody big on the passer the only
option they have is to throw it toward
the rim kelden fought through three
warriors to get that basketball
and